- So we're going up the
California coast right now
to try the best, coolest
cheese in California.
The amount that I actually know
about this is almost zero percent.
And I just said yes without
knowing what it meant.
We're driving up the coast,
we're about to eat crazy
quantities of cheese in three days.
Woo, I just walked outside the gas station
and this is what Liz
is doing. Why? (laughs)
- Cause when you sit for so long
you have to work your legs.
[Ashley] Can you do a
handstand right now? Do it.
So, we're about to pull up to
Stepladder Ranch what's the
deal with this place?
- [Liz] First one!
So this is a small goat farm.
It's one of the last remaining ones.
And, they make this cheese with beer
that I really want to try.
- Ready to eat some cheese, cheese!
- Let's eat some cheese!
- Wow, this is crazy!
- It's stinky, in a good way though.
- It's like when you open up
a container of mozzarella.
- It's like a little bit like a fart.
We're a little excited.
Wow, could have been a cheese
maiden in my other life.
You look like you were
meant to be a cheese maiden.
What's that for?
- This is a cheese trier so we're going to
take it into the aging
room and try it out.
- It looks like something
- Looks like an eye gouge
- you use to dissect a human body
- This is both my dreams and my nightmares
- [Liz] This is crazy.
- [Worker] Basically this
guy's about a year old
so this is one of our wheels
of cloth-bound cheddar.
- [Liz] Oh my god.
- If I were drunk I would
do this all the time.
- [Worker] Drinking and
cheese is dangerous.
(wows)
- Cheers.
- Here we go.
- Oh my god, cheese is
so fucking good, dude.
Like you look at that and
you're like that's disgusting
and then you eat this
you're like that's amazing.
- [Worker] One thing
better than beer and cheese
is beer and cheese.
- [Ashley] Yeah together.
- This is our Riley Run, we'll wash it,
and the Libertines stays on
Once you add the beer to it,
it really brings the funk out.
A little stinky a little fruity.
All kinds of stuff like that
- [Ashley] Just like Liz.
- Thank you.
- Ooh.
- Ooh, did you get the rind?
There's so much of that
beer taste at the end.
- I can totally see it like
mixed into a grilled cheese
or on some mac and cheese, like mmmm.
- [Ashley] On the
ultimate cheese road trip.
- [Liz] This is literally the
- When you first said
ultimate cheese road trip
I didn't think about how many farms
and how much cow poop it would involve.
- Yeah.
- I was thinking we would stop at nice
cheese shops, a couple whole foods,
we're like out in the boondocks.
- We're doing it real.
We are going to a cheese-making class.
- [Ashley] There's like literally
a cow outside your window.
- [Liz] I know.
- This is a cheese that
we're making today.
This is Broncha.
Broncha, again, is a blend
of both goat and cow's milk.
- [Ashley] It smells great in here.
It smells stinky and amazing.
- [Liz] Super stinky,
but it's delicious.
- We're about to dip in this lemon kefir,
Liz is chomping at the bit.
- Whoa.
- Yeah, wait, that is amazing.
- We have a blend of
both goat and cow's milk.
- Have you ever just like
taken a bath in this?
- I dream of doing this.
(laughing)
He'll add the rennet,
stir it in, within 20 minutes
it'll be completely
gelled up like a jello.
- You can smell the creaminess of it.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna leave it completely
undisturbed for at least 20 minutes.
(folk music)
- Pull it straight.
- Oh, it's thick.
- [Ashley] Wow, it is.
Oh, I see.
- We're gonna touch it.
- It looks like tofu, to me.
Oh, it's warm.
- You're gonna scoop up some curds.
Elizabeth, come on.
- Oh, I'm scared.
- It's like gold-digging.
- Got it.
- So, this is just water,
- Whey.
- Like, extra water.
- Yep, it's whey.
- So, this is, from start to finish,
we've made cheese, now.
- We made cheese.
- Yay.
- Cheers!
- [Whole Group] Cheese!
(laughing)
- [Liz] Love it.
We are heading up to Point Reyes Creamery.
So, I know how much you love bleu cheese.
- I do love bleu cheese.
- I hate bleu cheese.
- (laughing) Are they
known for bleu cheese?
- They have great bleu cheese, yes.
- Oh my god.
I'm pretty sure bleu cheese
is made with penicillin,
like actual medicine.
- That doesn't surprise me,
because that's what it tastes like.
- My name is (mumbles).
We are in Point Reyes
Farmstead Cheese Company
and we'll be tasting our cheeses today.
- Great, so what is this one called?
- This one is Toma.
- Oh, it's very soft.
- You know, basically
when you taste cheese,
you want to smell it.
- Mmmm.
- You can see that the
texture is very elastic.
So you will have a texture of
kind of a very creamy havarti.
And Bay Blue, actually is,
I like to call it a gateway blue cheese.
- If I try this, then in theory,
I'll be able to like blue cheese.
Just put a lot of honey on it.
- Cheers.
- I like bleu cheese.
- I think I could actually
finish this bite but,
that's probably only the first
bleu cheese I've ever eaten
that I've ever liked, so.
- [Ashley] This is first
favorite bleu cheese.
This is the Marin French Cheese company,
and they have a beautiful little
lake by their creamery.
- It's lovely.
- Have we had enough
cheese yet today, Ashley?
- (laughs) Oh my God,
we've had so much cheese.
People keep asking me where we've been,
and I have no idea.
Cheese.
- Cheese.
- Stop eating it!
- It's good.
- I'm sharing a hotel
room with Liz tonight--
- I'm gonna burp cheese
on you all night.
- And oh my God.
- Liz literally
just said to me--
- While we shit.
- I need a vegetable.
I haven't even been pooping.
- We just got back in
the car after dinner,
and we immediately rolled down the windows
because it smells like a thousand farts.
- It smells like an asshole.
- So, we are driving up to the farm,
and we just saw a bunch
of freaking buffalo.
Those are not cows.
- Just thought we'd switch
it up a little bit today.
- Cheese adventure.
- [Worker] We're gonna move
them over to the street pasture,
so they can have breakfast.
- Great, how do we get down there?
- ATV.
- Hold on Liz!
- What's happening?
(screaming)
- [Ashley] Oh my God, look at all of them.
- So, there basically just
gonna come across here,
and go over there for lunch.
Let's go get lunch!
- They look like I do when I want lunch.
- This is so much like
lunch at our office.
- Here we go.
- We're gonna milk water buffalo.
(laughing)
- These are water buffalo,
they are from Southeast Asia.
- [Worker] So pinch.
- I can't do it.
- [Ashley] You can do it.
- [Liz] It's like scratching your head
and rubbing your belly.
- [Liz] I did it!
- There you go, you got it out.
- [Liz] You did it!
- [Worker] There you go.
- That's how you milk
the buffalo. (laughs)
- Oh, she just snorted.
(buffalo crying)
- [Ashley] Cheers.
- Cheese.
- This is a lady made cheese, I love it.
(laughing)
- Oh my goodness.
The other cheeses we've been eating,
we've kinda want them
paired with something,
but I feel like mozzarella's
one that it's better fresher
with just a little bit on it.
- I can really taste the
freshness in it, too.
It feels like it was just made recently.
- It was just made.
What I've gotten from this
is that buffalo make incredible cheese,
but they're amazing animals.
- It was amazing.
I thought it was really cool
to see how the cheese was made,
and we tasted a lot of great
cheese, but I think like
all great things--
- Our car smells lie farts
- Everything in moderation.
You just fucked up my last line.
- Cheese road trip!
- Yeah!
- Oh my God.
No more dairy on our
next road trip, please.